Brad Pitt has been nominated three times
in the acting categories but is never
one but some are saying he's winning in
the dating Department people were going
bananas they were literally losing their
minds over the rumor that he is dating
Charlize Theron here's what et has
learned a source tells et Brad and
Charlize have known each other for years
but became better friends after working
on this commercial together six months
ago now there are rumors of a romance
but our source says well quote they
enjoy each other's company and connect
on many levels neither of them are ready
for a serious relationship right now
in fact we're told at Brad and Charlize
are both quote very single at the moment
and we're Brad finally decides to settle
down again quote he plans on dating
outside of the business he isn't looking
for an actress as a lifetime partner
he's ready for something different but
right now
Brad's focus quote is all about his
career and his children and it seems to
be paying off today's Oscar nominations
include Vice and a bills drink a talk to
films produced by Brad's company Plan B
entertainment Brad started the company
in 2001 with then wife Jennifer Aniston
plan B has since produced three Best
Picture Oscar winners the departed
starring his pal Leonardo DiCaprio the
coming-of-age story moonlight and 12
years to slave this would not have been
made without Brad when the film was
complete they had this also just this
extraordinary feeling that this is a
film that will that has legs that will
that will be around and be speaking to
people for for many many years and and
that's the biggest prize and by all
accounts the two times sexiest man alive
is a great boss just asked by star Amy
Adams did Brad Pitt do any actual
producing on the moon well yes he came
to set one day I had been in makeup and
I was wondering why all the girls wear
it like had lip gloss just that my real
name is Brad Pitt was born with it yeah
big goals okay stay right there
no I wouldn't really prefer to voice him
right now I just I'd rather do him Brad
has come a long way from our first
interview with him back in 1990 it was
just one year before his breakthrough
role and Thelma and Louise
and even then he had definite plans
first future well unfortunately a lot of
television to me is a fast-food fashion
show a lot of it and it's because of
money and time and I understand it has
to be that way but gets kind of
frustrating because I wish they would
spend a little more time with things
like that that's me though I'm not
paying the bills well it's got the bills
more than covered these days and as Brad
the producer he's got eight projects
currently in production in fact the last
time we actually saw Brad starring in a
movie was 2017 s Warmachine we are here
to build and then there was his blink
and you miss it cameo at Deadpool - a
role he did for a very small fee
according to Ryan Reynolds I was told
all he wants claw is a cup of coffee and
I just loved it because it's just what's
more irresponsible than taking you know
one of the biggest movie stars in the
world and giving him a role that is
utterly wordless and invisible
Jerry's vaudeville yeah I'm not letting
us see more bread yeah but also what
brad is done with Plan B you know so
make it right has been fantastic
[Music]